- [Instructor] So we are
given this function h of x,
and we're asked, over which interval
does h have a positive
average rate of change?
So like always, pause this
video and have a go at it
before we do this together.
All right, now let's work
through this together.
And to start, let's just remind ourselves
what an average rate of change even is.
You can view it as, the change
in your value of the function
for a given change in
the underlying variable
for a given change in x.
We could also view this as,
if we wanna figure out the interval,
we could say our x final
minus our x initial,
and in the numerator, it would
be the value of our function
at the x final, minus
the value of the function
at our x initial.
Now they aren't asking
us to calculate this
for all of these different intervals.
They're just asking us
whether it is positive.
And if you look over here,
as long as our x final is
greater than x initial,
in order to have a positive
average rate of change,
we just need to figure
out whether h at x final
is greater than h at x initial.
If the value of the function
at the higher endpoint
is larger than the value of the function
at the lower endpoint,
then we have a positive
average rate of change.
So let's see if that's happening
for any of these choices.
So let's see, h of zero,
this endpoint, is going
to be equal to zero.
If I just say 1/8 times zero minus zero,
and h of two is equal to 1/8
times two to the third power is eight.
So 1/8 times eight is one minus four.
So that's going to be,
this is negative three.
And so we don't have a situation
where h at our higher
endpoint is actually larger.
This is a negative average rate of change.
So I'll rule this one out.
And actually just to
help us visualize this,
I did go to Desmos and
graph this function.
And we can visually see that we have
a negative average rate of change
from x equals zero to x equals two.
At x equals zero, this
is where our function is,
at x equals two, this is
where our function is,
and so you can see, at x equals two,
our function has a lower value.
You could also think of
the average rate of change
as the slope of the line
that connects the two
endpoints on the function.
And so you can see it
has a negative slope,
so we have a negative
average rate of change
between those two points.
Now what about between these two?
So h of zero, we already
calculated as zero,
and what is h of eight?
Well, let's see that's 1/8
times eight to the third power.
Well, if I do eight to third power,
but then divide by eight,
that's the same thing
as eight to the second power.
So that's going to be 64
minus eight to the second power minus 64,
so that's equal to zero.
So here we have a zero
average rate of change
'cause this numerator's going to be zero,
so we can rule that out.
And you see it right over here.
When x is equal to zero,
our function is there,
when x is equal to eight,
and you can see that the slope of the line
that connects those two points is zero.
So you have zero average rate of change
between those two points.
Now what about choice C?
So let's see, h of six
is going to be equal to
1/8 times six to the third power.
So let's see, 36 times six is 180
plus 36, so that is going to be 216.
216 minus 36,
216 is six times six times six,
and then if we divide that by eight,
that is going to be the same thing as,
this is 36, and then we have 6/8 of 36.
So this is going to simplify
to 3/4 times 36 minus 36,
which is going to be
equal to negative nine.
You could have done it with a calculator
or done some long division,
but hopefully what I just
did makes some sense.
It's a little bit of arithmetic.
And so, at h of six, we have
our function is negative nine,
and then h of eight, I'll draw a line here
so we don't make it too messy,
h of eight we already
know is equal to zero.
So our function at this endpoint is higher
than the value of our
function at this endpoint.
So we do have a positive
average rate of change.
So I would pick that
choice right over there.
And you could see it visually.
h of six, when x is equal to six,
our value of our function
is negative nine.
And when x is equal to eight,
our value of our function is zero.
And so, the line that
connects those two points
definitely has a positive slope.
So we have a positive
average rate of change
over that interval.
Now, if we were just
doing this on our own,
we'd be done, but we could just
check this one right over here.
If we compare h of zero,
we already know is zero,
and h of six, we already know
is equal to negative nine.
So this is a negative
average rate of change
because at the higher
endpoint right over here,
we have a lower value of our function,
so we'd rule this out.
And you see it right over here,
if you go from x equals
zero where the function is
to x equals six where the function is,
it looks something,
it looks something like that.
Clearly that line has a negative slope.
So we have a negative
average rate of change.